je crois qu'il y a en avant aussi une
question d économique et géopolitique
avant tout on est on est dans le soft
power on est dans la question du
contrôle de l'avion pourrait dire du
cerveau des gens mais on est aussi dans
l'argent et on est aussi dans qui va
contrôler on pourrait dire les grands
moyens de communication et aussi les
grands moyens financiers parce que le
effectivement dicton est un sera sans
doute très rapidement à une machine à
cash très très important donc je crois
qu'il faut re médecins dans ce dans
cette perspective et faire un parallèle
par exemple à propos de roy ouais il ya
quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire abordé l'histoire de
roi ou en ce moment les etats unis font
en sorte que rob ruijgh n'ai plus accès
à un certain nombre de composants de
haut niveau de high tech pour tout
simplement casser l'entreprise d'une
certaine façon c'est à dire qu'on est
dans une situation où les entreprises
américaines et l'état américain essaye
de choisir finalement les entreprises
les grosses entreprises qui vont
contrôler les marchés futurs delà de la
communication alors omet évidemment de
l'idéologie là dedans mais enfin pour
l'instant on pourrait dire que ceux qui
sont les plus forts sur le contrôle tout
de même des esprits même dans le domaine
culturel etc etc sont les américains
c'est à dire que pour l'instant les
chinois ont quand même une image une rue
une image internationale extrêmement
négative et je crois que le gouvernement
chinois si vraiment il veut influencer
la jeunesse va avoir beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes
[Musique]